it was only 30 years ago that I was
sitting in the audience just like you
are and I distinctly remember feeling
this incredibly strong desire to figure
out how I could build my full life not
just my work life Tom will remember we
had our oldest kid I had my oldest kid I
should say my wife had our oldest child
the first day of finals of fall term
first year and it was sort of a
fascinating one those fascinating life's
lessons and I'll just start with this
story because I showed up to the GSB
everyone kind of remember first term
kind of really stressful you come in and
like oh my god am I qualified look at
all these smart people I'm highly
achievement accomplished oriented I need
to do really really well so I'm gonna
freak out and stress out like everyone
else I don't want to fall behind no
anyone had that experience I showed up
saying you know what I don't have to do
well because I have an excuse I have an
excuse everyone can understand because
we're about to have our first child
right due date the first term of finals
and so that term was one of the most
interesting experiences in my life
because while I saw a lot of my
classmates freaking out I would sort of
go back to Escondido village in the
married students housing those funny
people that had children and I wasn't
freaking out and sure enough jack was
born the sunday of finals I remember
going to marine McNichols it was her
first year teaching financial accounting
first year at the GSB giving her cigar
during the prep session but that that
first term of Business School I got five
H's and it wasn't because and Tom will
attest this it was not because I was one
of the smartest guys in the class we had
a lot of really smart people in our
class but it was because I didn't let
myself fall
to the narrative of the group of the
community of the norms I gave myself
permission maybe to fail and as a result
I succeeded and so what I thought I'd
just do this morning this afternoon is
share a little bit of my experience and
some lessons learned I've learned from
others over the past thirty years and
I'm going to share different stories and
anecdotes there's there's no perfectly
woven theme and I would just say two
things upfront and I'll say these when I
come back at the end number one
hindsight is really easy and hindsight
sounds really good so I will tell you
these things as though I would all
weaves together perfectly and it's all
simple and insightful and I'll tell you
there wasn't one moment during the last
30 years where I was certain I was doing
the right thing there wasn't one moment
when I was in the middle of it that it
felt oh great I got this all figured out
I still don't and so I just want to say
upfront it's gonna sound good in
hindsight but actually living it is is
it's a different story and then the
second thing I'll tell you is um life's
hard life's hard and once you accept
that and see that's the beauty of it in
some ways a lot of the other stuff gets
easy but let me start out but three
three simple themes one a question do
you want to be world class to your real
life can be a competitive advantage your
whole life can be a competitive
advantage and three do you want to win
and if so it'll be hard so one who here
wants to be world class in your career
who let's say you're gonna be a CEO or
an investor or an entrepreneur who wants
to be world class right who wants to
have a family life and a set of
friendships that are that are just
outstanding yeah me too
early on in my career I went to a talk
by a guy named Jim Jim Lehrer and he
talked about the concept of a business
athlete and he said same question I just
asked you he said you know what's so
interesting when you look at world-class
athletes they want to perform they're on
the playing field and they want to
perform at the highest levels and for
every hour they're on the playing field
they prepare 10 to 20 hours and they
invest in themselves they don't assume
they're gonna be able to walk out
perform on a world-class stage with no
preparation they invest in their bodies
they invest in their minds they invest
in their skills they invest in their
weaknesses they take preparing
themselves really seriously and they
view that as a sign of strength not a
weakness the narrative about business is
whether you're a CEO or an entrepreneur
or a great investor that all we just
work all the time
we don't really sleep or eat anyone that
we got a coach or god help you a
therapist that would be a sign of
weakness you never show your weakness
it's all strength and that somehow we
just assume we're just going to be able
to jump on the playing field a
world-class playing field just perform
and as he said this to me I was a young
consultant at Bain at the time I thought
this makes a lot of sense that actually
the narrative of investing in yourself
investing in all parts of yourself if
you want to have a full life made sense
and so the first set of things I would
just share is taking care of yourself
investing yourself now part of its easy
investing in your body eat decently
exercise sleep I this is the one I keep
relearning the sleep thing like you know
you get going and you going you're going
and you say oh I'm grinding my way
through need to catch up on sleep and I
watch my productivity goes
right Jim Collins who was a great
professor here has a has a wonderful
framework for sleep he says he tries to
get 70 hours every 10 days he can't his
life doesn't allow him to get 7 hours
every night but he's found his body
equilibrium and he works to get 70 hours
every 10 days and I found that to be a
useful framework so taking care of your
body and having it be ready to be
perform your skills this is perhaps the
easiest piece investing in your skills
right understanding what are your
strengths what are your weaknesses how
do you learn how do you build your
skills I had a great learning early on
at Bain about learning I came out of
business school with the pair the
narrative of how you learn is I was
gonna I was going to find someone in
business who was gonna mentor me and I
would be down at his or her knees like
the they'd be like the the wise Buddha
conveying all the wisdom about how I
could be successful and I would be the
students in front of a room with there
was a teacher and I'd learned everything
from this individual and here's what I
realized fairly early on that actually
no one person was going to be able to
teach me everything
in fact after a couple years he realized
actually you're better than your mentor
on some things and I realized I had the
same near the same paradigm in life that
I had in school that like
teacher-student and that's not how it
works
that learning I realized if I wanted to
learn I could learn a little bit from a
lot of people not a lot from a few and
it changed my narrative about learning
where I feel like I can learn from each
person I interact with I can learn from
each meeting
I don't just learn from my bosses I
learned from my peers I learned from
people I don't know and here's the funny
part my brain I've trained my brain to
say what can I learn I was just having a
wonderful conversation with Matt where's
Matt we just introduced me backstage I'm
earning from him and what I found is
when I meet someone I look for their
good qualities because I want to learn
from them and then people sense that I
know that I'm looking for the good
qualities so they tend to open up and
respond and it increases the cycle of
learning as we're most people kind of
set back well is this guy smart enough
you know and so in building your skills
learn from everybody you can learn from
everybody every example you can learn
what to do what not what to do but
learning I've had coaches I have had
multiple coaches I have a have a
therapist which we'll come to in a
minute I have a spiritual coach both a
Jesuit and a Buddhist I've had work
coaches team-building coaches we have a
couples therapist Eileen and I do it's
like if you're a world-class athlete you
want to get coaching that's a sign of
strength not weakness and there's some
great resources out there some great
resources to build your skills and to
share your life
the last area I'll say if there's body
and skills they'll probably least talked
about maybe most important is your
mental emotional and spiritual health
and interesting that there's a lot being
written about this right now a lot being
you know anyone here Golden State
Warriors fans right the four principles
is mindfulness they have 14 principles
all-around principles of mindfulness and
the notion that performing at the
highest levels is only possible only
possible when you have mental emotional
and spiritual balance each of us finding
our own and so as I said early on I came
out of business school I was feeling
incredibly stressed incredibly stressed
two years into my career pain I came
back and saw a professor here at Jerry
Porras who put me into contact with a
woman named Jill Melek who's a therapist
and in Palo Alto and I've seen Jill on
and on for 30 years
she's an enormous friend and resource as
I try to live my life I've always feel
like seeing a therapist is a sign of
I don't know strength not weakness I'm
not afraid to say it I don't think I
could have processed my life alone she's
helped me process my life some priests
Jesuit priests I met here at Stanford
now a buddhist jack Kornfield have been
an enormous source of support and help
and inspirations at key times again
helping to develop all parts of myself
one of the things I learned in therapy
was I had this massive fear of failure I
was I was feeling anxiety early on in my
career at Bain even though I was
technically doing well I was just
becoming racked with anxiety and what I
learned through a couple years of
therapy was actually I just had this
massive fear of failure and you know
what parts of that still exist today
parts of myself I'm continuously
learning it's like oh there's some
familiar friends there's version
14-point o of the same thing but
consciousness about who you are
consciousness about your proclivities
consciousness about your habits of your
mind is such a such a gift because then
you can recognize it oh there I go again
unfeeling anxious or there I go again
I'm feeling insecure at least my
experience is I have been able to figure
that out on my own I go out and get help
the last kind of help I just share is
building community which is sort of what
you're doing with each other my wife and
I have felt so blessed because we've
built community around us where we share
our lives with our community and it
starts in small ways I when I joined
Bain out of business school where there
was eight of us
that were part of that class and we just
agreed that every Friday morning or the
first Friday of every month
we would meet at the exact same
restaurant for breakfast and anyone that
was in town would come and we just kind
of end up sharing our experience and we
did that over two three years and and
watched is each of us went through her
ups and her downs and then we'd start
somewhat you know I started saying god
I'm having such a difficult time with my
boss or the travel is just wearing on me
I'm so tired
and someone else would say oh yeah I'm
having that here's how I've been dealing
with it and we didn't solve each other's
problems but there was a sense of
sharing in community and we've had the
same thing we've had a couple's group my
wife and I had a couple scroop we met
with five other couples for 15 years
once a month sharing our lives through
young childhood in the process built a
sense of community
and in a sense that community was an
investment in ourselves so first point
if you want to be world class you have
to invest in yourself and all this stuff
that some people think is kind of fuzzy
I don't view it as fuzzy I view it is
the only way you can actually perform
and perform at the highest levels second
theme your whole life your real life can
be a source of competitive advantage
again I learned this by accident I was
married when I showed that to the
business school in fact I was married
and as I said earlier we were gonna have
a kid so we never had time to figure out
personal life and professional life we
started early and it was all one life in
this notion of neg zero-sum framing I
actually hate the word work balance life
balance because it suggests that there
you know it's work or life it's my
wife's career or my career it's our
children or our career and so it
immediately frames things as zero-sum
and then a term like life balance
suggests there's an answer
so we've always tried a very positive
sum mindset which is not either-or it's
how do we find the best of both
acknowledging we'll never get there
acknowledging there is no Nirvana one of
the lessons I've learned through
experience accidental experience to some
extent around dealing with how you
balance family friends career is don't
be afraid to ask because creative
solutions can evolve first experience on
that so we had our child my first year
Business School and the same year my
wife applied to Stanford Law School and
she got in so we had the young baby
she's going to start law school I'm
gonna do stuck in your business school
she's not really into babysitting or
nannies or anything so we agree that the
right thing to do is for me to go in and
say to the Dean I'm need to either take
the second year off or I need to go
part-time because we were very anxious
about it while she's starting law school
so I went into Jerry Gould who was the
Dean of Student Affairs at the time and
I said Dean Gould I need to either take
the year off or go part-time and she
said okay that's fine
no I first said I need to pee you're off
and she said well you don't have to do
that at a minimum we can go part-time
and I said you go part-time I didn't
know you go part-time
is there any policy and that she said no
but we can figure that out you can go
part-time so then it said okay I can go
part-time how does that work she said
why don't you just pick the classes you
want to take and the first week just
show up to those classes and if you show
up to four classes great and if after a
week or two weeks you think you need to
drop down to three or two or one you can
sure enough what happens I show up to
four classes and after a couple weeks
it's kind of working it's kind of
working I didn't need to go part-time
but I had to give myself permission to
give it a try I never would have tried
it had this is again the lesson of not
being afraid to fail giving giving
herself permission to do something
that's counterintuitive
and I actually graduated on time and it
was a wonderful year so again that don't
assume don't make assumptions you can or
can't do something a second example five
years later four years later
Eileen finished Stanford Law School and
had a clerkship yeah
clerkship for the federal judge in San
Francisco and she had to be in judge's
chambers every morning at 7:30 300 and
well every weekday of the year at the
time I'm working at Payne
I am out of town all the time we have
two kids and so my conclusion is I've
got a quit bein so I walk into Tom
Tierney who was the guy running the San
Francisco office of Bane and I say I'm
Tom I gotta quit you know Eileen Scott
she's gonna have to be in judge's
chambers every morning which means I
have to take my two kids to school every
single morning this year which means I
cannot travel even once so I just need
to quit
and he's like Donahoe you idiot he used
to call me Donahoe you don't need to
quit well fine you know we'll put you on
a local client now at the time bein San
Francisco had zero local clients like
Tom we don't have any local clients if
you haven't noticed like we're all
traveling a lot he says we'll go get a
local client and so two weeks later he
takes me up to fireman's fund up in
Novato he says to the fireman's fund
execs here's the deal I'm gonna give you
a free Bane case team led by this guy
Donahoe and so it's a free team now
after three months he's got to figure
out to get you to pay him pay Bane but
in the interim it's free by the way he
can't ever be here before 10:30 in the
morning see ya
that was the most productive year of my
career turned out developed a great
relationship with the people at
fireman's fund they totally accepted I
wasn't gonna be there before 10:30 in
the morning cuz I had to drop my kids
off and in fact they are learned they're
respected and admired I was having a
positive some now there were some bein
partners at the time that thought I was
weak that somehow and some mutt some o
my peers thought I was weak you know
he's he's dropping out of that upper out
thing or he's got a I had no choice it
didn't bother me I did not listen to it
so what not the whole world's gonna tell
you what's wonderful when it happens but
it worked it worked and it was
ironically the most productive year of
my career third example of don't make
assumptions and be willing to ask for
permission so about seven years ago my
wife is a big supporter of President
Obama she's been in law and human rights
her whole career so he appoints her to
be ambassador to the Human Rights
Council in Geneva I'm CEO of eBay and we
have two kids still at home in high
school so we think okay how are we gonna
make this work now we were a little bit
further along in our lives and so we
talked about it with our kids and our
kids are like are you freakin crazy mom
do it go we'll figure it out we'll make
it work
and our kids gave us permission and we
made it work we made it work in a way
that that was some of the richest
periods of our family history our older
kids helped the younger kids it was just
it was just wonderful so your full life
can be a competitive advantage in your
work life if you're open minded and
you're willing to assume creative
solutions may exist engage others by the
way in your personal life here
what I've learned in my personal life my
kids don't give a about my title me
giving them orders or acting like a boss
never works I've learned listening from
my relationships I've learned empathy
for my children I've learned humility
I've learned how to multitask I've
learned the importance of just
resilience and staying with it by the
way those things really matter and work
it turns out any of you want to be
leaders those things actually are pretty
important qualities of being a leader
and so again is youth look forward don't
think about your personal life versus
your professional life I'm not saying
it's easy and there's some Nirvana but
understand learning in one can
contribute to the other last thing and
that will open up the questions again I
go back to my earlier how many of you
want to win on a world-class stage not
just perform but to win okay
turns out that's really hard just for a
minute
think about I want you to think about
just for a minute a period in your
career where when you look back you're
most proud a period would you learn the
most and grew the most in your
professional capacities just think for a
moment now think for a moment for a
period in your personal lives that when
you look back you say you know I
actually grew as a person I look back
with some pride and fondness on this
period of time
how many of you were those periods
either profession your personal where
things are going really really well okay
for how many of you with those courage
when you're confronting adversity yeah
that's been my experience here's the
bizarre thing the things I'm most proud
of in hindsight were really hard in the
moment they didn't feel good in the
moment and I realized I spend my life
hoping I can set myself up so I really
feel good I want to feel great about my
family
I want everything to be going well I
want to feel great about my career I
want everything to be going well and yet
the periods that I look back on with
pride and fondness and the periods in
which I know I grew the most were the
periods of adversity and so I've had to
learn how to not be afraid of adversity
now I can I tell you I enjoy adversity I
can tell you that when I confront
adversity now when adversity is dealt to
me professionally or personally I I
don't like it if you could give me an
out I take it but I can tell myself you
know what I'm learning I'm growing I'm
doing something for which I will feel
pride if I sustained and have the
courage and commitment and resilience to
get through it and here's the
interesting thing about performing on a
world-class level it's really hard I'll
use two sports analogies so apologies to
take global football soccer to those in
the u.s. so it's a wonderful wonderful
sport I love the World Cup because
almost every country on Earth gets to
have their national team and a couple
hundred teams start and start playing
each other and start right whittling way
down you start with out in a hundred and
fifty two hundred countries and you get
to the World Cup Finals the best two
teams in the world on the pitch for 90
minutes
and these teams have great players great
strategies are well prepared and the
games are ugly right
dear people getting dirt on their shins
on their uniforms
there's injuries there's back and forth
and all the great strategies kind of get
tossed out and it's a battle it's a
battle right you know the final score
the last four World Cups 1 0-0 0 to 1
and 1 0 the difference between winning
and being the World Cup champ and not
being the team no one ever remembers is
one goal it's not who believe me when
you're in the middle of that game it's
not like I'm just rocking dudes like
we're Brazil we just pass it all over
the place it looks great no it's the
opposite it's it's who capitalizes an
opportunities better Germany their best
player gets injured right in the
beginning of last World Cup and the
substitute scores the goal to win the
game in overtime right anyone remember
this anyone from France
making one mistake or one capitalizing
one opportunity didn't seem winning and
losing and when you're in the middle of
it anyone watching NBA Finals last year
you think it was fun to play in those
games no it is a pitched battle it is
hard it is overcoming adversity it is
committing to teamwork it's having the
resilience to bounce back it's having
faith that you can prevail on the end
but not knowing until the last minute
about whether you will that's what it's
like so instead of me wishing I was like
in some cool place where everything's
going all great I realized no I want to
play in a world-class stage and I want
to win and it's gonna be really hard and
I'm gonna feel like I have a lot of
adversity along the way and I don't like
adversity but at least I know I'm
growing at least I know I'm doing
something I'll be proud of one last
story gets back to my fear of failure
it's Matthew serine here where are you
Matthew this is a story about your dad
Matt Matt that's the second year had his
dad was my first boss at Bain one of my
best friends a hell of a boss tough boss
but a hell of a boss and a great man and
early on in my Bain time during that
paragraph having this fear of failure
I'm just racked with just anxiety he's
like there's a baseball analogy
apologies to anyone that doesn't
understand baseball think you'll get the
gist of it he's like John your problems
you're trying to bat 900 can't like what
do you mean he's like well when you were
in college you got A's which mean you've
got 90% right you were in business
school you got HS which means you've got
90 percent right and so you're assuming
that you've got to get 90 percent right
to win but now you've gone from the
little leagues to the junior leagues to
the college to now you're in pro and
guess what the pitching is really good
good fastball good curveball and you
were so afraid to strike out because you
don't want a bat you're afraid you won't
bat 900 that you're paralyzed you don't
want to get in the batter's box
he said best I can tell
greatest hitter in baseball history
batted about 350 which means every ten
times he came up to bat he could strike
out six hit a couple of singles an
occasional double and be the greatest
hitter in baseball history Kent says he
know what you best I can tell
being a leading hitter in business is
similar to in baseball you got a bat 315
if you're gonna play against if you
wanna play in a world class stage said
you know what instead of being afraid
you can't bat 900 get in the batter's
box and swing and sometimes you're going
to strike out sometimes you're gonna
strike out with the bases loaded and the
stands full but all you got to do is get
a couple of singles occasional double
and maybe an occasional home run
get in there and swing and you know what
I've been a CEO of two companies had
four children a dual career lot of
experiences batting 350s actually not so
bad you can't Pat 900 in life so once I
let go of trying to bat 900 once it was
whether it's coming to the GSB my first
term or or you know dealing with Carl
like on eBay well you got to do is bat
350 and don't be afraid to get in there
and swing the power of resilience the
power of commitment commitment to
yourself and commitment to the journey
is the thing that I think differentiates
the people that win and those that don't
last thing I'll say before I'll turn it
over to your questions or whatever you
want to talk about it sounds so easy
it's so easy for me
with hindsight to tell you these stories
these learnings these blessings I've had
there is not one moment in the last
thirty years where Eileen and I were
certain we were doing the right thing as
parents
there's not one moment where I've been
certain about whether I'm being a good
father or not I can tell you I get a lot
of credit now for the ebay turnaround
there was not one moment in the middle I
turn around that we were certain we were
gonna make it right and again part of
the goal part of the part of the the
purpose is just that commitment that
impatient to build a full life and the
commitment and the resilience to pursue
it and then the faith that ultimately
ultimately it's a life worth living so
let me stop I'd be happy to answer
questions or talk about any topics you'd
like to I just want to ask you as you
said you have to sort of like practice
it and then sort of keep reiterating and
building their muscles how do you retain
that memory of resilience because I've
passed that struggle and then I'm facing
another one anxiety about planning a job
like how do you sort of remind yourself
it will be alright and then you if you
pass through it and then how do you even
make that happen
I mean you talk about spirituality and
and meditation and mindfulness I would
be happy to listen more know what
granularity you have on that one thank
you I'm looking for a job right now so
you and I are together
all right so I'll tell you what I'm
doing we compare notes seriously and you
talk about one of the best things I've
had the last year off first time since I
left the GSB 30 years more time first
time I had more than three weeks off and
I've taken the last year off and one of
the best things I did was I did a 10 day
silent Buddhist retreat up at Spirit
Rock great resource anyone want a spirit
rock they have one day programs 3d
programs guy named jack Kornfield sort
of founded the center and I wasn't I
wasn't big into this beforehand but the
power of meditation has been a wonderful
gift for me and and here's the image
here's the image that that I took out of
that retreat that the Buddhism the Dalai
Lama would say is not a religion it's a
science of the mind
so left brain guy like me that's
interesting and you start looking at
brain sciences and one of the
interesting xin brain sciences there now
documenting two things one your brain
becomes more negative over time because
they talk about the brain bad
experiences having a Velcro experience
on your brain good experiences having a
Teflon experience that's pouncing off
and it's it's Darwinian it's natural you
know we would step out you step in front
of a car almost get hit by the car boom
your brain remembers that don't do that
again your brain remembers that
unconsciously consciously a beautiful
sunset you maybe your brain may or may
not remember it so over time our brains
actually magnify tough experience as bad
experiences if left untended but the
second thing they're proving is that you
can actually train your brain to
counteract that you can train your brain
to be more I'll say equanimity are not
even happier but have that quantity and
the image they use that really helps me
is they talked about how every every
person is deeply imbued at birth with
what they call Buddha nature and
spooning nature is simply kindness
generosity compassion and love and that
every they would say every sentient
being but every human being at Birth has
deeply imbued with those qualities
whether you're born into Isis or into
Africa or into a certain right every
human and it's always there inside of us
it's like the blue sky the blue sky is
there every single day in history at
every single point on earth there's blue
sky up there but what happens is clouds
right some days it's sunny blue skies
but a lot of days is cloudy some periods
aren't some periods around the some
places on earth there's a lot of clouds
sometimes they're dark clouds fog you
just think about how and when it's foggy
or cloudy you forget the blue skies
above the clouds right you get you get
your mood gets impacted by that and the
clouds are nothing but air and so what
happens to us and this happens to me is
I get clouds and I lose sight of my
Buddha nature clouds can be habits in my
mind fear failure it can be my my
experiences it can be distractions like
digital life like he gets so fragmented
and so I walk around at times like
feeling like there clouds coming over I
forget my Buddha nature and when I
forget my booty nature that's when I get
insecure or that's when I begin to get
anxious and what meditations been for me
is just simply waiting so I wait a
minute there's just some clouds I kind
of I got a see through the clouds let's
see the blue sky which is my Buddha
nature that kindness generosity
compassion and love are deeply inside me
and when I can connect with that
then you know what I might figure out
the job saying I don't know how it'll
happen I don't know when but and so for
me the process of meditation is just one
of of just reconnecting with that turns
out meditations hard too but so I'll see
you at the unemployment office we can
collect our checks together all right
we'll go we'll go here okay great yeah
you can hand the mics to whoever and
then I don't have to pick i I'm tannin
MSX program so they're more than just
MBA students here yeah I just want to
understand from your perspective how
important it is in life to win because
you know you seem to talk about it a lot
but can't we afford to lose to promote
the interests of others I mean in the
context of your you know Buddhist
philosophy and all there seems to be an
awful lot talked about winning you know
for oneself and maybe for your
organization but about losing you know
is is that something that we need to
embrace somehow you know for the
interest of others or the interest of
society as a whole
yeah I think it's a great that's a great
question and you know I think what's
it's how we define winning for me
winning I set goals for myself when I
was at the GSB about I want to be not
just a successful business person but I
want to develop a rich and fulfilling
life to the best extent I can and so it
I think each of us has to define what is
our own version it's it's our own
intentionality our own aspiration
intentionality and not always listen to
what everyone else is saying about
winning and losing so the first thought
that comes to mind is that each of us
defining what is your aspiration for
yourself in your life what what what do
you want to commit yourself with
intentionality toward it could be toward
world peace could be toward
helping people that have lost I mean it
could be a lot of different things and
then to your point even in that game
losing's often the best lessons in life
the best lessons in life so at least for
me I've always had that image of I want
to win but win on the things I care
about
and winning doesn't always mean that
someone else loses or that other people
recognize winning parenting is a
wonderful example of this is parenting
you don't get that like little scorecard
along the way and if you listen to it
too much you feel like you're losing a
lot but when your children get older you
you look and you say we am i proud about
who they have become and that's that's
winning that makes sense
it's great it's a great question so
don't let others define if you let
others define winning and losing they'll
define it zero so I'm not positive some
and ear write society and and and and
our world right now is a little bit very
zero-sum oriented and you could argue
that we need a different definition of
winning
who's got the mic over I have a question
about your relationship with your wife
that's the type of relationship that at
least I'd like to have with my partner
reasons like one of the things you know
at any point in time you two we're a
team and we're kind of like optimizing
for both of you rather than just being
like and so on could you share something
could you share how you grew personally
into that relationship I'm sure it
changes couple to couple but at least
for you how did you make that happen
like how did you find that balance in a
couple so the first thing I'd start I
just want to talk to the men in here I
have one piece of advice to you based on
my experience find someone who is
smarter than you
nicer better-looking and a deeper person
and personality and marry her because
that's what I did and and I do think in
all seriousness you know we met in
college and and we talked her Herrmann
maiden name was Chamberlain in mine was
Donahoe we talked about chamber ho a
partnership I'm Sur totally serious
chamber ho and then we had chamber hole
1.0 and a little later in our marriage
chamber ho to point O and when she went
to Geneva was chamber ho 3.0 and in that
was just sort of a we had no answers by
the way on any of this stuff again and
in in a dual career marriage family
saying it's even more than work stuff
it's really easy in hindsight it's
really a journey I you know I'd say the
quality I'd I appreciate the most about
my wife is that she demands that I
become a better person she actually
doesn't really care about my career and
my successes she does care about the
kind of person I am and I've always felt
her presence and her both expectation
and encouragement and her role modeling
on it and I think she'd probably say the
same
she'd say the same in response and you
know a marriage is a marriage is a
marriage is a work of art it's a piece
of work it's hard it's hard but if you
if sort of like parenting if you have a
commitment to try to okay we're gonna
try to see this through we're gonna try
to make this work it you know we feel
really lucky community the value of
community around marriage has been huge
for us other couples we had this I
described this couples experience
couples group we've had five and you
know we've got like
all right it's the second Saturday of
the month we've got her we've got her
teams of Our Lady meeting this like Oh
God we don't want to go to this meeting
we're so busy we're so stressed we are
kids this blah blah blah god I really
don't want to be going to this and we go
and people would start talking about
what's going on in their lives and time
we just and after three or four hours
you get in the car to go home and thank
God we don't have it as bad as they do
and and I mean that in the best sense of
the word right we're just sharing our
experiences and it was a little bit of
perspective here we are we're so
obsessed and up you know about ourselves
and our own lives and our own situations
and crises and this and that and what
you get in community you realize hey
wait a minute that's that's what it's
about that's what it's about so I will
say she's also had a tougher by the way
to the women in the group I've we both
written about a little bit of this on
some of Cheryl's Lena and stuff she's
had a tougher path career path wise
which he was working at a law firm the
same time I was working it at eBay or at
Bain rather early on and there was
definitely in our generation and I think
still to this day women have a tougher
path you know the dev Grunfeld I used
Deb's wonderful you haven't had her
class here I used to heard eBay she's
got this narrative that that male
leaders can be both smart and likable
and female leaders the ones that are
smart are perceived not to be likable
thank Hillary Clinton and ones that are
likable must not be smart and that that
it's not just men that project that on
women it's women that project that on
women as well and so Eileen was always
one of the smart ones and and she used
to get performance review feedback
saying you shouldn't be so direct
shouldn't be so direct you know and she
was just cut through the clutter her
boss used to go out drinking get all the
guys going out drinking after as we had
to
kid she didn't want to go out drinking
so I I also think it's been a
fascinating watching her go through our
career paths and I have a lot of
admiration because she's had a tougher
path than I have
I think that's changing a little bit but
it's still there's a lot of way to go in
our society in that so thanks for the
question
next question who's got the mic I've got
it alright so first John just thanks so
much for coming here to speak with us
today
I just wanted to pivot back to the to
your thoughts on mindfulness and
meditation and you know one of the
things is that you know it's easier to
see the blue sky or at least to notice
the clouds when you're either doing a
one-week silent meditation and you know
Bhutan or you know when you're sitting
in your room by yourself but that can be
much harder when you know you're in the
midst of 12 hour day at the GSB or
managing a multi-billion dollar company
and I just wanted to know if you had any
thoughts on how to better integrate
those practices into the workplace
you know either specific things that
you've done or opportunities you see for
for better integrating those two yeah
it's it's it's a hard I can speak
personally about how challenging that is
and here's the sort of strange thing
about in my case I could always make
time to work out but making time to
meditate somehow felt harder it's like
well that's kind of stupid I can work
out my body but not my brain and then I
began to doing a little bit I'm old
enough now I've had knee surgeries that
basically working out means writing an
extra cycle I know I try to I listen
I'll ride the extra cycle listening to
meditation music try to do a little bit
of both you know sometimes it works
sometimes it doesn't but the I mean the
only way I've known is trying to put
habit in jack Kornfield had a wonderful
little piece of advice because he talks
about having mindfulness just in little
moments
not in like 20 minutes of you know
sitting like this you know for periods
on end but he's just in a moment of the
day and and I sorry if any what this
offends anyone but he says every time
you go to the bathroom take a moment a
little trigger every time you wash your
hands every time you do whatever just
take a moment and sometimes that works
for me and sometimes I'll go through two
three four days I'm now to the point
where I begin to recognize the symptoms
so when I don't do it and then I feel
resistance to doing it which is like the
best symptom that I need it but you know
having common practices and then trying
to break it down into work doesn't have
to be gigantic swathes of time so we've
reached the end of our Q&A time
unfortunately we've got about three
minutes left
John had something he wanted to say yeah
I am
I discovered anyone here heard of John
Gardner John Gardner was one of the
wisest men around he was he was
secretary of huw under President Kennedy
and then was in Johnson's administration
and he was at the GSB when I got here
and he wrote a lot about personal
renewal and the the importance of
personal renewal and about 20 years ago
I found a paragraph that he wrote that
just grabbed me and it sort of it became
my I don't know if the personal mission
statement but it's a touchstone for me
and I literally have it laminated in my
wallet and I just want to close by by
reading it because it's it's something
that has I read this probably once a
month I pull it out meaning is not
something that you stumble across like
an answer to a riddle or the prize in a
treasure hunt
meaning is something you build into your
life you build it out of your own past
out of your affections and loyalties out
of the experience of humankind as it is
passed on to you you build it out of
your own talent and understanding out of
the things you believe in out of the
things and people you love out of the
values for which you are willing to
sacrifice something
the ingredients are all there you are
the only one who can put them together
into that unique pattern that will be
your life let it be a life that has
dignity and meaning for you if it does
then the particular balance of success
or failure is of less account so anyway
I'll and where I started I just I honor
and bless you
and congratulate you for caring about
building meaning into your lives for
this journey Iran and the commitment you
have to making it a fulfilling and
meaningful journey and I wish you the
very best of luck thank you